hello everyone welcome to this nana
string sponsored webinar for another
labyrinths coronavirus virtual event
i'm your host
my name is elizabeth schneider i'm the
senior global marketing manager at
nanostream today we have the pleasure of
presenting um dr camilla margarelli from
the university of alabama at birmingham
and she will be talking about spatial
transcriptomic profiling of severe
covid19 patient
camilla received her phd in immunology
and molecular pathogenesis in 2019 from
the graduate division of biological and
biomedical sciences at emory university
during her thesis she studied the
mechanisms leading to neutrophil
plasticity and chronic diseases
with a primary focus on
infants and adults affected by cystic
fibrosis
she's currently a post-doctoral trainee
in dr ahmet gagar's group
and she continues to work on mechanisms
regulating airway inflammation in acute
and chronic viral infections
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
communicating with other attendees using
the new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen and you can
also participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits and thanks everyone for joining
and thank you camilla for presenting
we're looking forward to your talk
thank you for having me and thank you
all for being here
um so as elizabeth said today i would
like to present a study that we started
when actually the kobe plan 19 pandemic
hit in 2020
so our aim was to define the
transcriptional profile of the lung of a
copylanding patient to try to gain
insights on this noble disease
so as you may know
covenanting patients and
many other viral infections actually
lead to
ards
or uh cupid territory distress syndrome
and this includes also the
h1n1 influenza pandemic that we had
previously
both h1n1 and sarsko v2 actually have
been characterized by increased
inflammation in the lung
and also increased disease-related
morbidity and mortality
however a key difference is that sarcoby
2 patients compared to influenza
patients that present with ards
showcase the extended hospitalization
which means that probably the cellular
responses in the lung
are different between these two uh
patient cohorts
so in order to address similarities and
differences in these two patients cohort
we used another novel platform
offered by nanostring which is called
spatial trans transcriptomics so it
allows you to stain um fixed tissue
and that has been paraffin embedded
and basically label it with rna probes
that are
tagged with oligos
and then also come back after that with
an antibody staining as you would do
immunofluorescence to identify different
cells of interest
so what we did we obtained um autopsy
tissue from three copy 19 patients and
also
three
patients that were from the h1n1
pandemic
and also we had one patient that was
double infected with both h1n1 and
kovin-19 and psycho b2
so we stained these tissues
for epithelium macrophages
and also
endothelium so the three major cell
types that you would find in the lung
and then profile the tissue both as
general areas as you can see here so as
a mixture of cells but also we from
those general areas we were able thanks
to the feature of the machine
to extract a profile just for a specific
cell type
so either epithelium or endothelium as
you can see on slide but also just for
macrophages
so
after you select these areas the machine
allows you
um to
shed the linkers
and uh sequence the oligos from those
rnas that you hybridized
and then basically sequence those oligos
and then
map them back to which rna they
correspond
and we used a panel of about 1800 gene
for each area of interest or each cells
of interest
so we selected initially areas that were
that showcased
damage or specific for their ards as you
can see here indicated by the black
arrows
they showcase hyaline membranes
which are
a key feature of ards and you can see
that we have them both
in all three cases but in kovi 19 in
h1n1 as you can see here but also
in the double infected patient
and we extracted rna from those but we
also went a little bit deeper in our
analysis and we decided to select areas
where
viral staining for surgical v2 or h1n1
was highly present as you can see in one
and two
although two is a little bit dark
h1n1 should be in red
and then areas that showcase no viral
presence in these patients to see
whether there was a difference
so in terms of general areas
um
each patient showcases differential
transcriptional profile as a total
profile uh with sarsko v2 clustering
together h1n1
patient
and double infected clustering
in another area of the pca analysis
suggesting that the their profile is
probably
more similar
um than to sargo v2
we then proceeded to analyze the gene
transcription signatures for those areas
more granularly and you can see here
that sarsko b2 actually had a distinct
profile with several genes that were
upregulated or down regulated compared
to h1n1
but also compared to the double infected
patient
and if we looked at the pathway analysis
of these genes that were differentially
expressed in these patients you can see
that there are several
pathways that are actually
unique to sarcobi2 including innate
immune system aptly along the
mesothermal transition
platelet activation which was already
described as
increased coagulation in this station by
clinical observations
and
you can as i said
extracellular matrix organization was
also really
increased in this uh kovi 19 patient as
you can see here by a pathway of
um
collagen deposition
and accelerometric scholars
organization as you can see there are
several genes that are implicated in
that
so we next
analyze the
vascular bed of the
lungs to see whether we could pick up
the same signatures as we saw in the
general areas in specific cell types so
as you may remember we observed that
there was increased genes for
coagulation and also placal aggregation
so from the general area we selected
specifically
endothelial cells and the
vascular beds
both in the h1n1 sarsko b2 but also the
double infected patient and
say the same pathway that we observed in
the general tissue showed up also here
including coagulation uh elevated
platelet platelet activity and
aggregation and hemostasis
so suggesting that um there is a genetic
or transcriptional reprogramming of
these cells in sargo v2 compared to h1n1
which actually results in clinical
outcomes that have been observed with
increased
thrombosis in this patient cohort
we then proceeded to analyze the
epithelium as a another major cell type
in the lungs
and as you can see here there is a clear
difference in genes that were
um
upper regulated in sarcope2 compared to
h1n1 or compared to
the double infected patient and as of
note
um the double infected patient also
resembles very much the h1n1 profile in
all of the cell individual cells but
also the general areas
so as you can see here similar to the
vascular bed we observe the same
pathways
that we're up regulating in starsky v2
including
external magic organization
some motility integrin signaling
so and so on
we then observed that covenanting
patients
actually
had
metaplasia of the alveoli
so the alveolar epithelium compared to
h1n1 we in which it was not observed and
as you can see here but both hne and
also the immunofluorescence staining we
observe these clusters and which were
observed also in other studies
and so we profiled this cluster compared
to a normal epithelium as we saw in the
previous slide to see whether there were
any differences in terms of um
gene expression
so as you can see here
we
phenotyped the normal epithelium
compared to hyperplasia and there were
very few genes that were
differentially expressed between these
two epithelial
states
however in the apoplasia there were
several genes as you can see in the heat
map
that um
including k ras that basically are
associated with cancer but also
epithelial proliferation which were up
regulated in the hyperplastic epithelium
compared to
the normal one in surgical v2
finally
we phenotyped also the macrophages
from the tissue and as you can see here
this is where the beauty of
this technique comes handy
where you can have a mixture of cells
like that but just extract
only the cells that you would love to
phenotype so this is something that um
is really useful especially if you don't
want to isolate them straight from the
tissue but
also maintain their spatial
location
so as you can see here there were also
several genes that were differentially
expressed between sarsko v2 and h1n1
including genes that were
in the um
they basically define m1 and m2 um
macrophages with
surgical v2
patients showcasing a very skewed m2
phenotype in these cells
as highlighted on the right in the heat
map
suggesting that there are differential
inflammatory processes in these two
infections although the clinical
outcomes sometimes
may be similar
so
in conclusion we
showed you that
this technique called special
transcriptomics is actually
very useful to maintain the tissue
architecture it removes the bias
of isolating the cells and then perform
rna sequencing on them
while still giving a really
robust transcriptional profiling of the
cells of interest
there is an evidence for more for a more
uh fiber
fibro proliferative
ards phenotype inside kobe 2 compared to
h1n1 which
may implicate or may define why this
patient are actually staying
longer in the hospital and have longer
intubation times compared to
those that
are hospitalized in the su
because of h1n1
infection
we also showed you that there is a
chance for dual infection of patients
with both kobe 19 and h1n1 which is
probably a reality that we
may look forward to in the next few
years
where more and more cases of dual
infection will show up
now we only had one patient in our
cohort so take this with a grain of salt
but
if it holds true and the dual infection
actually resemble more the h1n1 profile
is actually probably a good thing um
because it requires lower
hospitalization times
but also a higher chance of survival
and also
um there is differential immune
phenotypes compared comparing staroscopy
to infection to h1n1 or the dual
infection which should lead to probably
different um therapies for these two
patient courts
um however it requires a more
in-depth analysis with temporal
analysis of how these transcriptional
signatures develop
but also
um
how exactly these cells interact with
each other which will require extensive
studies for that
now for this
work i have to thank a lot of people it
was a very collaborative effort with
between the department of pathology
our um
the the doctor that performed the
autopsies and um manustring as well
which they were really helpful
to guide us through this
and
with this i would like to
love to take any questions and thank you
for your attention
thanks so much camilla that was a really
interesting and engaging presentation
and uh now we will open up for our q a
[Music]
well welcome everyone to the q a session
for camilla's talk uh i hope you all are
ready to ask her some questions
so please go ahead and submit them
through the chat and i will go take a
look now and see if there are any
questions in the q a
so the first question that came in is
actually on the next direction for your
research so camilla could you tell us
what you might do as a next step for
your research
um sure um so i have to mention that
this was not the only project going on
in star scooby 2 in our lab and
we've been exploring more on the
immune side and immune response
of the lung
and basically found that there is a
subpopulation of neutrophils that
actually help clear the virus in the
lung
so
the next step will be to actually try
and see the evolution of sarsko v2 but
also
what happens if there are any
differences between people that
develop long cobit
and people that actually don't because
there aren't a lot of data
out there on what could be the
differences between
these two subgroups
of patients
excellent yeah we look forward to seeing
that data come out
so another question that came in um so
this study was all about the lung
and i understand that your lab focuses a
lot on the lung um do you plan to do any
of this work on any other
tissues that were taken from rapid
autopsies of some of these covenanting
decedents
yes so we are actually
investigating the heart right now
um
because obviously there are a lot of
complication systemically
and we
found
some viral staining in the heart as well
and is in concordance with
data from other groups
but yeah that's that's the next step and
then i know that there are other groups
that are looking at the gut for example
but um we have no plans at at the moment
to investigate
that issue
okay
yeah i'm excited to see what your
results um are with the heart because i
know that there have been a lot of
people that have had um you know issues
um with the cardiovascular system um
after having contracted sars cove too um
another question um that came in um did
you look at any um comorbidities that
any of these
patients had where you profiled their
particular lung samples and whether or
not that you know had an effect of what
type of transcriptomic profiles you saw
yes so
that's actually a question that the
reviewer also came up with
obviously the most severe cases of covet
will
likely be linked to
existing comorbidities
in this population because they are the
more successful um to develop um severe
covalent than
trouble die of the disease so most of
our patients actually
had some comorbidity comorbidities
however they were
similar between the two groups
between 21 and hobbit
so
we didn't have the numbers of patients
to actually
dive more into the questions of what
comorbidity could lead to certain
transcriptional profiles
because of the limited numbers but
it's definitely an interesting question
that should be answered
in the future
excellent
thank you so much so let's see if we had
any other questions that came in through
the chat
so um another question it looks like
they came in is um could you comment a
little bit on the geomex digital spatial
profiling platform and how
difficult or easy to use it was
potentially compared to some of the
other spatial transcriptomic platforms
that might be out there
um sure
i think um i may be a little biased but
i i really like the platform
if you have access to uh paraffin
embedded tissues
um it gives you a
a really good um
flexibility on what you can study in the
tissue
and also um you know
keeping the
the um
the architecture of the tissue um
without isolating the cell so that
reduces the bias um the analysis part is
very straightforward as well
on the platform everything is integrated
so
it's been it's been a pretty pretty good
experience and i think um
i don't know if that's known out there
but
we are waiting on the single cell also
transcriptional profiling
to see how that will perform because
it will be a really really good
technique to have
excellent yeah and i think you're
referring to um the nana strings spatial
molecular imager that is going to be um
developed and released i think sometime
next year um so yeah we're all very
anxious to see that as well
um so another question that i had is um
you know one of the advantages of using
the geomix digital spatial profiler is
the ability to select different areas of
interest that you want to profile um and
compared to say you know some other
platforms that are out there for spatial
transcriptomics that um force you to
kind of look at everything in the tissue
and you can't really focus in on
specific architectures or tissue
structures
you know with genomics you can actually
go in and
almost like trace out you know what
parts of the tissue you want to profile
so i was wondering if you could give us
some an idea of like your profiling
strategy of why you chose the regions of
interest
that you picked for your spatial
transcriptomics
sure um so we went for the main
structural cells that are resident in
the lung
we picked obviously the epithelium
because that plays a major role
in the physiology and pathophysiology
we pick the endothelium or like vascular
bed i should say
and then the resident macrophages
however we initially debated whether we
wanted to go for the whole immune cells
or
for just a subtype but we decided to go
just for the
main
like structural cells that are there all
the time to see
their behavior you know in severe coded
so we take uh we yeah we take those
cells uh specifically in areas of um
uh the presented lesions so hyaline
membranes which are
characteristic of ards
that has been developed by the kobe 19
patients when
they get
in this in the severe state
so another question that came in is um
you know obviously a lot of these
samples were taken before everyone was
trying to get vaccinated
um and we do know that there have been
some breakthrough infections that have
happened in some very rare cases
patients who are ending up being
hospitalized after being vaccinated in
some cases twice with moderna or pfizer
um are you guys going to get access to
any of any of those samples and
potentially do some spatial
transcriptomics on them to compare them
to people that were not vaccinated
so um we haven't had many cases of
people that were vaccinated and actually
succumbed to the disease
um the tissues that we use that's what
we want
it's really it's a really good uh
good thing
but uh so what we used was a toxic issue
obviously you cannot really do huge
biopsies of the lungs when patients are
still alive
it's different than with other organs
for example
so
we
so far we don't have any cases
here at uab it's possible that probably
nationally we may start to see some
coming up but um i don't know whether
we're going to have access to that but
it will be definitely interesting to see
the main differences also between the
variants too and you know why certain
variants are
more infectious and
put more people in the hospital than
than others
yeah that's a very good point um i
didn't even actually um think about that
um so another question that came in is
um you know dr greger is a pulmonologist
um you know do you um have access to any
samples where potentially like a lung
transplant patient um you know
contracted cover 19 and you know looking
at the spatial transcriptomics of those
potential samples um you know and
obviously there are a lot more
considerations for someone who's a
transplant recipient they might be on
immunosuppressive
yes so there are several factors to
consider when you get a transplant issue
obviously
um
like they got a transport for a certain
reason first of all um which may alter
the transcriptome in the first place
um
and then you know on top of that you
have the virus and on top of that you
have immunosuppressants so
um
it will be interesting
um
i'm not sure
whether we've had
many transplant cases lately because of
the shutdown of the whole
medical alteration
um
covet um so they limited a lot of the
procedures they're starting back up but
i'm not sure about the access to those
samples but definitely it could be
possible
excellent
well thanks so much um so this is your
last chance to submit questions um so we
have camilla here live who did the
spatial transcriptomic study on lung
samples from superior copa 19 cases
so please you know go ahead if there's
anything that you wanted to ask her
please go ahead and submit it through
the q a chat portion of the console so
um we will give a few minutes for people
to ask questions um i guess in the
interim is there anything else camilla
that you would like to add you know to
this
presentation that maybe you know you
didn't get to talk about when you know
you you presented it something that's
come up recently
um
knob that i can think of
okay excellent
all right
well i didn't see any more questions
come through so thanks everyone on the
line for tuning in to the
lab roots current virus virtual event
series
really appreciated your attention
um you know if you have any other um you
know questions um feel free to um you
know submit them through the chat and if
we don't get to them labyrinths will um
collect them all and i will reach out to
camilla and try to answer them as best i
can so thanks again everyone
thank you
bye